Flying in a plane nowadays is about as safe
as catching a ride on a bus or commuting on
the subway.
Of course, that doesn’t stop people being
afraid of flying.
To some, the prospect of long-haul flights,
or feeling the shudder of turbulence, are
reasons to avoid planes altogether.
And then, every year there are stories of
downed flights or those that go missing, all
adding fuel to that aviophobia fire.
Take, for example, the infamous Bermuda Triangle,
that well known region of the western part
of the North Atlantic Ocean.
What does that have to do with a fear of flying?
Well, famously a high number of aircraft are
believed to have mysteriously vanished while
flying over the Bermuda Triangle, their wreckage
and passengers rarely ever recovered.
Stories like that are enough to make anyone
think twice about setting foot in a plane
again.
And then, there’s SCP-787.
As you may have already guessed, SCP-787 is
a plane.
Specifically, it is a Boeing 747 200.
With a wingspan of nearly two hundred feet,
and capable of seating over eight hundred
passengers, the 747 200 is part of the famous
Boeing 747 family of aircraft.
These are quad engine commercial airliners,
designed to be the safest ever built.
The particular Boeing 747 200 that has since
become known by the Foundation as SCP-787
is slightly different from one that might
take you from your nearest airport to your
long awaited vacation though.
For one, SCP-787 has no known date of manufacture
and no call sign, both which a standard Boeing
aircraft would be expected to have.
Additionally, the plane’s entire exterior
has been repainted; strangely, even the windows
have been painted over, and the paint was
still wet when SCP-787 was first discovered.
As for the inner workings?
All of SCP-787’s mechanical components,
including its turbines, engines and landing
gear, are in perfect working order, with no
signs of any damage.
In fact, The SCP Foundation’s researchers
aren’t even sure that SCP-787 has actually
flown since its construction.
The plane’s machinery looks so pristine
that they might be brand new, with no detectable
signs of any previous use.
However, inside the main body of the plane
it seems to be a different story.
Anything not mechanical like the carpets and
seats have decayed over time.
Perhaps strangest of all is the cockpit.
Both the pilot’s and co-pilot’s chairs
have been replaced with two masses of computer
components, arranged to take the shape of
two chairs.
“So, what?” you might be thinking.
After all, SCP-787 is, for all intents and
purposes, just an ordinary plane.
Not enough to put you off flying, right?
Nothing more than a Boeing with a few little
things off about it like some missing seats
and decaying upholstery.
Well there’s that… and then there’s
the over five hundred dead bodies on board.
In June 1987, this flight of the dead was
discovered several kilometers outside of the
city of Bremerton in Washington State.
The SCP Foundation moved in, securing the
plane and swiftly getting it into containment.
Now kept within a Foundation hangar, the interior
of SCP-787 is monitored for twenty-four hours
a day.
Surveillance cameras and microphones are located
within the cockpit, passenger areas, and even
in the plane’s baggage hold, with recorded
footage and sound relayed back to the Foundation.
The idea of a plane filled with cadavers is
certainly unnerving, and more than a little
creepy, but why the need for all the surveillance?
After all, the bodies on board are all dead,
right?
Surely, they’re not going anywhere.
Well, let’s talk about those bodies.
How would you expect someone to die when they
are aboard a plane?
Maybe they’d be thrown around during a crash
landing?
Or perhaps a sudden depressurisation might
cause the passengers to suffocate due to a
lack of oxygen?
Under normal circumstances, you might be right.
But SCP-787 is no ordinary plane, and the
passengers on board were not killed in ways
you might expect for an ordinary aircraft
accident.
Referred to by research staff as SCP-787a
specimens, the cadavers aboard this particular
Boeing 747 200 all have dramatically different
causes of death.
Some of the specimens show signs of strangulation,
others seem to have starved or drowned.
Other bodies on board have injuries like gunshot
or stab wounds, while further corpses look
to have died as a result of blunt force trauma.
A few have even been exsanguinated, that is,
completely drained of all their blood.
One commonality among all the specimens on
board SCP-787 is that some form of mutilation
has occurred.
Twenty-three passengers had their tongues
removed, a further seventy-three were scalped,
230 had Cyrillic letters carved into their
left hands and almost five hundred of the
passengers had their fingertips removed.
Let’s recap what we have so far.
First, there’s a Boeing 747 200 found randomly
sitting in a field.
Second, it’s filled with over five hundred
mutilated bodies.
And third, each one appears to have died from
a cause you wouldn’t typically expect of
an airline accident.
Seems strange enough, but of course then there’s
the apparitions and noises that manifest inside
SCP-787, which is why the Foundation keeps
the plane under round-the-clock surveillance
so they can monitor any anomalous activity
taking place aboard this flight of the dead.
Any attempts by Foundation personnel to enter
the plane during an anomalous occurrence have
led to individuals being physically ejected
from SCP-787, causing severe organ damage
and internal bleeding for up to seventy-two
hours.
The anomalies that occur inside SCP-787 range
from the presence of loud noises with no obvious
source, to the manifestation of strange human-shaped
entities within the plane.
The first anomalous occurrence recorded within
SCP-787 was in 1988, when the sound of a loud
pounding was heard against the doors and windows
of the plane’s left side.
Two years later, a male voice could be heard
from the onboard bathroom, repeating a singular
phrase over and over: “Philosophers always
run from the advanced thickening treatment”.
In 1993, the plane’s in-flight entertainment
system seemed to be activated by itself.
The overhead screens showed a bizarre choice
of in-flight movie: colorless pictures of
a deceased man, accompanied by a female voice
reading a gynaecology book in Czech.
The same year, the longest lasting of the
SCP-787 anomalies took place.
This time, the plane’s “Fasten Seatbelts”
sign spent almost four hours flickering, while
the first fifteen seconds of Jefferson Airplane’s
White Rabbit played on a loop over the onboard
speakers.
It wasn’t until 1997 that the first of the
humanoid entities appeared aboard SCP-787.
This figure was indistinct, lacking any discernible
detail, little more than just a human shape
standing in the aisles.
Observed by the Foundation’s surveillance
equipment, the figure was seen removing an
emergency oxygen supply and mask from seat
H43.
It stood perfectly still, wearing the passenger’s
breathing mask for over two minutes before
removing the mask and disappearing from the
view of the cameras placed onboard.
The figure did not appear anywhere else inside
the plane.
Another figure appeared four years later in
2001, sitting in the mass of computer parts
that made up the co-pilot’s chair.
This figure, much like its predecessor, was
indistinct in its features.
For almost four minutes, it sat in the cockpit
of the Boeing 747 200, just whimpering softly.
Then, it lurched forward, vomiting all over
the console in front of it, before quickly
disappearing like the first figure.
SCP Foundation personnel collected a sample
of the vomit that the entity left behind.
After performing an analysis of the sample,
research staff found traces of nitrous oxide,
thorium, bird droppings… and three human
fingernails.
At present, the origin of these humanoid figures
is still unknown.
Could these entities be the souls of the dead
passengers, trying to offer insight into what
happened aboard this flight?
Or perhaps these indistinct, human-shaped
creatures are the ones responsible for the
deaths of SCP-787’s passengers?
The next anomaly within SCP-787 occurred in
2005, when a female voice was recorded speaking
through the onboard speaker system.
The voice said: “For your comfort and enjoyment
today, pancakes will now be served.
Please do not leave your seat.
Pancakes will now be served.
Do not leave your seat.
Leave your seat.
Please.
Pancakes will now be served.
Yaaaaaaaaaaaay pancakes!”
Exactly what the relevance of pancakes are
to the plane full of bodies is still under
investigation by the SCP Foundation.
Next, in 2007, the Boeing’s overhead emergency
air masks fell from the ceiling, only to be
snatched back upwards.
They continued deploying and retracting for
fourteen minutes, while the plane was simultaneously
filled with the noise of screams.
Finally, the only other notable anomaly took
place a year later, when the onboard temperature
within SCP-787 dropped thirty-three degrees,
from twenty to minus thirteen Celsius in a
matter of seconds.
By the late 2000s, the SCP Foundation’s
researchers were having little luck understanding
the nature of SCP-787’s anomalies.
Instead, they turned their attention to identifying
the bodies of the deceased passengers onboard.
Through the use of advanced forensics and
population databases, these researchers attempted
to determine where exactly these bodies had
come from.
Researchers still hadn’t determined if they
had all died on the plane, or if someone had
exhumed them from graves before placing them
aboard for some unknown reason.
In fact, the answer was neither.
And Foundation researchers discovered something
that no-one had expected: One of the passengers
was still alive.
To clarify, the body aboard SCP-787 was definitely
still deceased.
But researchers identified the cadaver as
a retired optometrist from Atlanta, Georgia,
who was still very much alive.
Foundation agents found that the man was simultaneously
alive and well at his Atlanta home, but also
dead on-board the Boeing 747 200.
The subject was interviewed by agents, and
had no prior knowledge of any incident taking
place in June 1987 when SCP-787 was first
discovered.
Even more interestingly, he claimed that he’d
never even set foot aboard an airplane, which
his wife and son both confirmed to be true.
So, what does this mean?
How could the same man have been alive in
Georgia and dead aboard SCP-787?
Perhaps the answer can be found in a surprising
place… the plane’s toilet.
Or to be more specific, the place where things
flushed in the toilet go to.
Examinations of the airplane’s waste storage
tank revealed something very surprising, there
was one more SCP-787a specimen that had been
overlooked.
It is unknown just how he got in there, but
researchers discovered the body of an Indian
man who looked to be in his thirties.
The man, who was wearing a three piece suit,
was found to be carrying a number of puzzling
items, including a surgical mask and gloves,
an unloaded Beretta DT-10 shotgun, several
cinnamon flavored mints, a switchblade knife,
an amulet that appears to depict the Eye of
Horus, and a ticket stub for the Return of
the Jedi with the number “92” written
on the back.
All of these objects seem to be completely
random, and the Foundation has been unable
to make sense of what they were doing on the
man, or why his body does not seem to show
the same state of decay as the rest of those
found on board.
There was one item that may hold some answers
though.
For some reason this man also possessed a
copy of SCP-787’s flight log.
The log consisted of a series of coordinates
which were repeated 5,478 times.
The coordinates point to a seemingly random
spot in the Pacific ocean, several hundred
miles away from the infamous Pitcairn Islands,
the island that the famous mutineers of the
HMS Bounty settled after taking over their
ship and leaving the captain adrift on the
ocean.
Is this location the secret to SCP-787?
While none of this is confirmed, nor denied,
by anyone at the SCP Foundation, one theory
surrounding the area is that the location
is another Bermuda Triangle like location,
one that contains some sort of temporal anomaly
that unwitting planes fly through, only to
find themselves displaced in time.
Of course, the problem with that theory is
that the man from Atlanta said he’d never
been aboard a plane before.
Or, at least not yet.
It is entirely possible that SCP-787 is a
plane that made a flight at some point in
the not too distant future, only to arrive
back in June 1987 by passing through a temporal
breach in the area near the Pitcairn Islands.
Sure, it might not explain what happened to
everyone onboard, but it could at least explain
how SCP-787 arrived where and when it did.
Every plane is fitted with a device that records
flight data, in the event of a crash or other
accident, known to most as the plane’s black
box, and researchers were able to uncover
SCP-787’s inside a compartment under one
of the plane’s seats.
The recorder was found within a compartment
filled with toxic asbestos and dried human
blood.
They hoped that perhaps it would contain some
answers as to where exactly SCP-787 had come
from, and what had happened to its passengers.
Sadly not, the flight data recorder contained
no information besides one simple phrase:
“TO BE SORRY.”
While an inexplicable mystery, SCP-787 is
at least classed as a Safe anomaly by the
Foundation, seeing as it poses no realistic
threat or shows signs of trying to break out
of containment.
The aircraft has only ever caused harm to
anyone trying to enter during one of its sporadic
anomalous events, but apart from that, it
sits gathering dust in a hanger, just waiting
for someone to crack its secrets.
And who knows, maybe one day you’ll be sitting
on a plane that’s taking you to your South
Pacific vacation, and the retired optometrist
sitting next to you will remark that you’re
passing over the Pitcairn Islands, and you’ll
discover for yourself exactly what happened
to SCP-787.
Now check out “SCP-354 - The Red Pool”
and “SCP-3999 - I Am At The Center of Everything
That Happens To Me” for more frightening
mysteries from the SCP Foundation!